[Music]
hello everyone welcome to the number-one
rated video podcast the random show and
what I mean number one I mean rated by
the people in this room which is the
three of us unanimously you know well
took some convincing episode number 396
that's right you are Kevin Rose I am Tim
barres here you thought guy so if you
haven't seen the show before we are a
couple of fools we talk about random
stuff that we run into throughout our
lives during the week or sometimes weeks
between these episodes sometimes months
between these episodes so it's all over
the place we hope you enjoy that I'm
acting like we're just starting the show
is a very herky-jerky feel like we need
that's what you get for not drinking I
know I'm just like beautiful company so
that Kevin's too sober to be relaxed for
our outing thank you for the tea
yeah absolutely what do we have him well
this this we have here is a ginger and
turmeric tea and it is from a company
called Rishi I think you're in Oakland
yes yeah when towards their headquarters
actually oh cool yeah because the other
one is actually also from Oakland who
knew Oakland was such a such a hotbed
this stuff right here is a stress less
tea so we have the the ginger and
turmeric and then this is rose petals
lemon balm skullcap and peppermint
I think we've I think we've synchronized
our cycles yeah it's back on cramps this
is good stuff I do like the I do like
the reishi tea as far as like if you're
looking for just a you know I don't know
$6 tea and it's good quality they like
the founder I met him he actually really
cares about his product he goes in
sources the tea it's not gonna be like
the artisanal I can pics like artists
and all you know talking about artisanal
like hand-picked like high-end teas that
you get at some places but it's it's
really good and you can go to Whole
Foods I by the integer and turmeric by
the box I love it yeah and it's it's
it's a really good touch to add to
almost any other type of teas so I'll
combine it off
in the morning with party and overcomes
a little of that sort of wet horse ass
barnyard smell of the poo air yeah ooh
air can be a little little tangy yeah so
I want to thank em and rob em and Rob
gave this to me as a gift
Emin rob of forage that is their company
this is a Heath ceramics mug and it has
a very unusual construction to it I
think this was the first mug they became
well-known for and it's because the
owner wanted to be able to smoke and
drink coffee at the same time pretty
badass I mean so this is a throwback
Heath for people who don't know they
they're made in San Francisco they've
been around for a long time so this was
like back when smoking kill with and
think you could die from it okay I mean
they've been around since or they just
didn't care there's still a lot of
hipsters it's sort of the defiance of
death that's true
they're still with their with their
plaid on skinny jeans but what's
happening Kevin ah lots lots of actually
since the last time we did one of these
shows obviously it's been we've done one
since New Year's that we I think the
last one was in November yeah November
yeah she's been a long time months and
months so I left Google Ventures I was
there you know about this I did I do
I was there for almost three years
actually which is kind of crazy it
started a new company why it started a
new company I was still Google Ventures
and basically the thing that I have a
hard time with and and you know how this
is being a like a multitasker that you
are as an entrepreneur and also an
investor and sometimes an entrepreneur
on multiple projects at the same time
it's like all of a sudden you know you
wake up in the morning you have a coffee
or two or three with founders trying to
vet deals for Google Ventures you go off
and your worker and startup in the
afternoon and then like there's no time
for anything else yeah I mean you go
home you have dinner then you get back
on your computer and it's just like I
was just dying it was like way too much
stress and honestly I need the focus I'm
a little a DD so like for me focuses is
really key and I just felt that at
Google Ventures I love the team over
there they're there
great folks Graham still works there
they're they're awesome but for me I
just like if I'm gonna do something I
have to be all in I feel really bad when
I'm sitting there and I have to tell my
team like hey I'm gonna be gone the
first half of today because I have a
board meeting to go to or something else
so I'm still having my portfolio
companies I still have you know
obviously a vested interest in their
success or the various funds that I'm
involved in but so I step down I'm just
gonna be an adviser to the fund now so
you know I'll bring the reveals I'm on
the startup yeah full time let's start
up I raised five million bucks for it so
basically that gives us enough runway
footballing grandma's just exactly it's
like a coffin I have people calling in
that would be amazing
which you could raise hands like that so
basically I went out and raised some
money and the the whole pitch to the
investors was that I want to go and try
some really crazy things and have as
many shots on goal as possible just to
try a bunch of different ideas I think I
talked about this when I was launching
north initially but in a previous
podcast but anyway we've got five people
we're cranking and you know I'd
mentioned my watchful app which is doing
quite well we keep breaking records
almost every single day which is nuts
for usage yeah and then I've got one of
the lab called tiny not doing so well
I'll probably kill it yeah but the whole
plan is just honestly is to aggressively
kill stuff that isn't working and just
go after the stuff that is working
euthanize them while you can still just
peashooter well the problem the problem
with startups in and I had a really long
discussion with a lot of BC's about this
is that typically when a company goes
out and raises money let's say they go
out and raise a million and a half bucks
two million bucks they feel like when
they raise it around a certain idea that
they need to stick with that idea sure
and really give it a shot and don't get
me wrong there has been a lot of
companies that they're I've seen them
stick with the idea and it finally
starts to gain some legs and they they
have as something that's a success in
their hands but I feel that I keep
saying I feel that I think that you're
full of feelings I know I often times
startups will stick with the idea for
too long and then all of a sudden they
burn through all their capital they have
to go out and raise around and it's
gonna be a down round or they won't even
be able to raise it at all and in I just
want to not go down that path
rather just like aggressively kill
something then rather than just be stuck
down a rabbit hole that leads to nowhere
uh-huh so that's that's the plan
I like that plan yeah it's good it feels
it feels good to be back in it like
honestly I think that you and I you go
through these like at least I go through
these waves of warning just like go out
there and take on the world and then all
of a sudden II was like oh my gosh it's
so much work and stress and then you
kind of like dial it back a little bit
and you go back in you dial it back and
I think that at least for me when it
comes to being a start-up entrepreneur
after Digg I had really I needed a
proper break yeah and so Google Ventures
gave me that three years I was able to
reset and now I don't feel burnt out I
could actually go in you know work at 8
9 10 hour day and it just doesn't even
like doesn't feel like work I'm just
having fun again I think there's a big
difference also between working on your
own projects that you can take from
start to finish with the help of a small
team and helping portfolio companies and
I enjoy both but I think it's very easy
to get seduced into only helping other
people build but there's something so
gratifying and invigorating about
working on your own oh for sure raft
yeah and for me that's content to the
podcast the audio podcast has been so
much fun for me and it's given me a
chance to develop a whole new set of
skills around writing basically to take
the one piece of it which is researching
where I do all these interviews and get
better at that so I've been you know
studying all sorts of masters of that
craft ended up hiring a gent who does a
lot of the research and prep for Inside
the Actors Studio mmm to look at
transcripts of some of my podcasts and
help me to think about how to order
things differently and so on and hmm
that exploration has been so fun for me
and it's part of the reason that I'm I'm
I'm really focusing on the writing again
for the first time in many years because
I just blew a gasket I mean it's maybe
not entirely analogous to dig but the
4-hour chef was such a traumatic monster
of an experience rooms like a three-year
project compressed into a year and a
half and
lost half of the team basically working
on it so I feel like after the last
number of years of sort of cutting my
teeth doing experiments with startups I
have the bandwidth and the enthusiasm to
come back to the mothership a little bit
and focus on that so the mothership is
your is your writing yeah what are you
writing now I am be talking my just blog
post so yeah look I'm I've been taking
notes for another book potentially
because I I'm always like ah no more
books no more books then I'm like oh my
god but there's gonna be another for our
book know if I do another book well
there's one actually that I am gathering
it two materials for which will be
4-hour workweek related because the four
hour work weeks coming up on its tenth
anniversary in a few years which is
insane and there's so many incredible
stories of people who went from
literally an idea to IPO with their
companies or people who have used the
principles in the 4-hour workweek in
ways you would never guess so actors
have used it to end up starring and
Super Bowl commercials and all sorts of
raisi stuff and then tons
I mean dozens of amazing stories of
families you've traveled the world so I
want to create a an encyclopedia of
success stories and case studies showing
the breadth and the variety of ways that
you can implement this toolbox that is
the 4-hour workweek so if you guys have
any success stories to share you can go
to 4-hour workweek com forward slash
success actually that's where you can
tell me about it and I would love to
hear it because this is that's going to
be a very meaty book but in terms of new
concepts like completely new directions
there are a few books that I'm taking
notes for but primarily
can you hint at all know for our
meditation no sex no for our good seller
yeah yeah for our sex there's already a
chapter for that for our body yeah
several chapters the the the general
approach that I've taken with my writing
and I'll be doing more of this in the
blog posts and I'm trying to do this
with a podcast as well as getting to the
point where I'm extremely uncomfortable
with certain aspect
of just vulnerability that I'm putting
on the page so the getting to a point
where I'm sharing certain trials and
tribulations and challenges that I've
faced that I might be when I put it down
like I can't say that and that's usually
when I end up with my most well received
posts that help people the most
interesting you should say this and so
are you gonna what would you do I've
been thinking about this a lot actually
okay why is that because so I have this
this other podcast that I'm served
couples in the foundation podcast where
I've done a bunch of interviews similar
to what you did more in video form and
so you know I was thinking about one
trimming those down and then two also
doing like a traditional interview where
I sit down with something like you know
like an England mosque for say like and
then in between those just do these
little weekly rants that are are more
just like just me getting something off
my chest
you're not no rant like I hate Comcast
like not something like that but more
just like what you're experiencing in
life like what you're going through like
some of the like you said the trials and
tribulations that you're going through
about different decisions that you have
to make and just like and opening that
up and actually setting that free you
know and just seeing what people do with
it but I don't really want it to be
public in a weird way so this is kind of
weird it's hard to get those love it let
me just walk the street Morgan's before
this this is like if you I don't even
know that they blonde it but if I once
you hear this but I think that in a
weird way I want to be a small group
like a private group but I don't know
how I would let those people in so I
would like it to be like you know a
couple hundred people that you could
like invite in and say hey if you're
like you've been following the stuff
I've been working on if you care about
these topics like you know maybe you'll
be interested in like these little rants
and give me feedback and we can have a
discussion like it's really difficult
when you put out a podcast like say
something like this or something that
you do right to gather all that feedback
and have a real conversation around it
right because I'm sure like anytime you
put out anything on video least for me I
get a bunch of out replies on Twitter
being like great episode or this and
that or like this part but there's no
structured conversation there yeah
and so I was thinking like maybe I could
do something where it's like something
really like a small little barrier to
get in like a couple bucks a month's and
what people would pay but I mean they
care enough about the content to like
charge for that and then have them come
in and have a conversation around it I
can interact with those people yeah
anyway you see them saying I see you're
saying because like you have of this
issue too like you probably have out
there like ten thousand people that want
to talk to you all at one time right
yeah that doesn't scale you're one
person right so like how could you
create how could you do this what you're
about to say you want to do and in a
more intimate environment where it's
just your most loyal hardcore fans yeah
you could actually have a real dialogue
well you know this is something I've
struggled with I think we've we've
talked about this before but I've I have
toyed around with the idea of having
basically what you're describing is sort
of a membership of some type that allows
people to get exclusive whether it be
access to say like a Q&A that you do
once every week month whatever it might
be your video I'm sure people would love
that actually there are people who want
it and then there are people who say a
lot of people in my audience who say
absolutely don't do that because you're
gonna end up in the you're gonna end up
getting lumped into the sort of internet
marketer group like grey zone yeah but
it's no different than like a band
having like a membership area where they
put our exclusive tracks for their most
hardcore fans yeah you know like the way
I look at it is like I would always want
the bulk of my content to be completely
free like when I do those interviews on
foundation there's some that information
should be free because it's helping in
rich other people's lives other would be
entrepreneurs that are listening to
someone awesome yeah so the little tiny
rants and bits in between like what
stocks I'm excited about what little
things that I'm into right now what
things are fun like that's the stuff
that I feel that like it takes the
dedicated hardcore people that like love
what you do it's the same people the
reason people subscribe to your
quarterly box I'll tell you why I get
your quarterly box we'll talk about this
in because I started correlate bucks too
but like I get your core like box the
cool thing about it is I'm like it's a
it's a little bit of you that is that I
would not talk about that right and I
and it's random
thank you I'm always that car app is a
mere hundred dollars a quarter no you
too could be a member
John you I've always pleasantly
surprised by what I get in it because
you I would never buy that stuff for
myself right and like sometimes there's
like a supplement and I'm like oh no you
really like that that was for my box
right yeah I always send them to have
them send I'm like market for Kevin's
box and two of those so it's it's just
saying I'm just saying that like you
live an interesting life you run into
really interesting people you have crazy
thoughts like if you don't if you've got
to sit here you would see that when the
cameras aren't on I'm like looking
around as books and [ __ ] and like you
write all in your books you have these
little meticulous notes and you you have
all these weird thoughts that people
want to see more of that
yeah and so this would just be a channel
to do that no I hear you well let's
let's talk through this a little bit
because I mean I'd love people's
feedback - I suppose both of us wouldn't
just use hashtag random and then hit us
on Twitter I suppose would be the
easiest thing how about a second random
show because randomly my yeah random
show so a hashtag ran our show but the
so I tried to do very briefly I used a
wordpress plugin for this so it wasn't I
didn't build it out for a membership
site and I was gonna charge five or ten
dollars it was this the four hour body
stuff that you're talking about back in
the day I did it I did it for such a
brief period of time I don't even
remember because I did it for a few
weeks and what I found is there though
the lower price point is very
problematic in my experience where you
end up with for instance I searched ten
thousand dollars a seat for this event
that I threw a couple years ago right
almost no complaints and it also gave me
sort of a lot of margin to play with
making the product meaning the
experience [ __ ] ridiculous I mean
super over-the-top at ten dollars a
month though there was a very high level
of there were people who wanted to talk
for hours you know via email or chat or
whatever it would be about what was
wrong with
hours and hours and hours and so I got
about two weeks into the first month and
I was like [ __ ] it I'm canceling I'm
refunding all you forget it I don't want
to do it and so I I don't know what
thick the sweet spot is that's it just
for getting the getting the diehards
right and it's the ones that aren't
because you don't wanna make it overly
cost prohibitive but you also want the
people to be truly interested in the
experience you're describing right and
that's not just like ah [ __ ] it I'll do
it
oh you're saying that at time they put
$5 and you're saying it $5 somebody's
gonna be like now that I have your ear
let me pitch you for x y&z you're like
right how can i how can you help me with
this and you're just like it's not about
that
right it's a setting the egg I don't
know man letting the expectations in
price point I think is challenging but
who knows if you guys would like that
type of subscription offering from
either of us listener your thoughts yeah
I'm at t Faris two hours two S's at
Kevin Rose right when are all single
consonants in his name so you've
mentioned before we started rolling some
new apps some new apps that you were
yeah yeah tell me about so I've got a
couple things one of the things that I'm
trying to do as I'm building on this new
company is that as with any founder
whether it has only five people total
you're wearing a bunch of different hats
and so I'm constantly running into
different people throughout the week or
a month that I need to keep tabs on yeah
I want to follow up with them I want to
check in with them from time to time
when vloggers retailers watch bloggers
retailers is their partners whatever
Amite there's like a hundred already
that I have right but how do you make
sense of all this stuff and then like
and in your professional life like some
people use like LinkedIn and I comment
on each other stuff but like how can you
do it in an email I wanted to all done
an email I want a reminder if I haven't
spoken with someone in a certain amount
of time I want to see if I have I just
had one other guy that's helped me out
with bizdev now I want to see when he's
last contacted one of these people okay
I want to be able to put them in bucket
so I can see like how many times we've
had a touch point with them or gotten
cold warm right exactly he actually does
like sexy hot stuff and then it it'll
show you when you have a meeting with
them last and so I found two solutions
for this I love again if people have
others hit me up on Twitter but
contactually which is pretty cool so you
can basically create a bucket let's just
say it's like you know investors
potential investors you create a bucket
30 days and then you drag your contacts
you link your Google so you author your
Google Account with it it pulls in all
of your emails and it looks all your
emails and then it you basically drag
them into this bucket and then if 30
days has gone by and you haven't
contacted one of those potential
investors it pings you and says hey you
should reach out to this person it's
been 31 days now and so I'm starting to
create all these everybuggy's that's one
that I used and then I started using
relate IQ you know relate IQ is pretty
badass like their plugin is by far the
best like it plugs into Gmail and you
can see right at the bottom of the Gmail
you can you can choose like follow up in
one week two weeks whatever it'll show
you really like awesome read receipts
and things like that as they're
happening it's it's just a little bit
more power to do more kind of scripting
in it do you know of any tool so the one
need that I have not been able to
satisfy maybe you have a solution for
this is just kidding is T's making me
frisky so no the the one need that I
have been o satisfied which has been a
problem really it's not a neat it's a
problem that I'm your old solve is if I
fly to god-knows-where it's like I have
a layover in Atlanta or in Charleston or
whatever and I'm like God you know like
I wish I knew which of my friends were
here or which of my even like kind of
secondary contacts or here so I could
call them and have dinner or whatever
yeah human does it human yeah where's
your hu am I in yeah it's uh it's this
kind of a replacement address book for
for the iPhone ok and you can go in and
say when I'm a certain area which of my
friends are also here and you
okay got it this is the iPhone yeah use
the iPhone to do that and so to let you
know like who's around interesting um
you obviously have to get your friends I
know more and more people are starting
to switch over it's interesting I
installed it just to play around with it
I'm not a hundred percent sold yet but I
think it's um it actually also updates
like your address book with like photos
from Facebook and their photos from
Twitter and like they can go in let's
say here's a good example this is one
thing that's really cool about it like
let's say you sign for an account okay
so it knows that we know each other
because our address books are synced and
I have your number and all that stuff
and let's just say that I'm using that
app and you know a month goes by and
you're like you know I'm gonna change my
email address I just got a new one you
type it in there in a human you click
Save and then all of your friends that
have human get that updated email
address right in their address book or
photo or phone number or anything that
you change that's it's pretty cool
anyway it's it's like one of the many
apps that have tried a really tough
space I think I dress books tough one to
crack I have the anti-human as an app
okay that is probably gonna get me in
trouble
it blocks it's called robot no it's not
called robot yes
it's called have something I have
something to show related to robots and
humans but that's more UT yes this I
filled this one oh did you okay yeah
that one's toast dog said I pulled a
handful of hair off nice single single
slamming of two Labradoodle yeah it's
hypoallergenic you know the oh yeah so
there's an app there's an app called
burner audio burner yeah yeah so a lot
of people don't know about okay so why
do you know burner because it's a burger
D it everybody knows that so burner for
those of you who don't know cuz I only
found out about this a few weeks it's by
the way I found out you can be traced
with burner you can be traced with
everything how do you get traced with
burner because you're on a frickin phone
they know that it's tidier while not
using it to buy like
warheads what do you what are you using
it for they tell me what it is far as ah
the burner allows you to create
basically throw away or temper
phone numbers for calling or texting so
if you like who knows whether it's like
you buy something on eBay you don't want
to give your phone number to some random
stranger what's up I love the idea of
using it for some like eBay yeah
eBay or I mean obviously people using it
for dating and stuff like that to online
dating whatever but the its it provides
you with a buffer where you're like okay
I do want to talk to someone that I
don't want to give them my phone number
that I can never retract is this on the
phone like is it working on the iPhone
oh yeah we're clever okay I need to get
this yeah and you can you I mean I can
kind of heard about it I never you have
five min fo numbers right now really you
just buy credit and then you can just
like just toss them and it burns them
and they're gone they're gone yeah you
said you you're not using to buy
warheads yeah no so because this
technology these these anonymizing
technologies can be used for evil
purposes
oh yeah well this one's yeah I looked on
the website they said that they comply
with all like government doesn't I don't
so you can still get screwed if you're
doing something super illegal yes you
should yeah but I was gonna ask you this
is a real question it's a joking
question but it's also a real question
oh I'm excited if do you think cuz you
know some [ __ ] like you know like how to
work the underground [ __ ] and all that
is that could you buy like a weapon like
a nuclear weapon us there with that a
nuclear weapon to be very hard you think
you're hard of course we are how about
just getting a little plutonium uh you
know I would have to think about I've
never looked for it I mean there are
markets for these things right I mean
there are buyers and sellers of illegal
arms so ostensibly if you have enough
money in the right contacts you could
have that ionization and you could
immediately have like a black hood
throne of your head and get thrown in
the back of a white van too well but
yeah I am fascinated by the stuff though
we got war by other means by masters of
war given me by a chess teacher slash
Brazilian jiu-jitsu blackbelt how to buy
a nuclear weapons right the art of
deception this is these are this is
Mitnick I've had this for years but this
is a social engineering stuff those are
some of my notes Tony I'm no idea I've
never tried I mean can you get yourself
into a lot of
probably heard about the was it Silk
Road the guy finally got oh yes did you
yes right here right like literally a
couple miles from a house but you're the
set up right how he got caught like he
some former business partner he hired an
assassin to kill him it was a little
deeper than that like well that was true
he did but they staged the death because
they needed the photo and then traced it
back to his laptop here in San Francisco
and they staged like a my livers quarrel
in the life that's right it has for me
right here up top open yeah on the
administration page of the Silk Road
these FBI agents start a fight behind
him to distract him and when he looks up
didn't like a woman and grabs him and
then the woman read my laptop while it's
still open and runs it out to the door
to the FBI guys who are like copying the
hard drive Wow Wow it was intense I
didn't know that that went down yeah
sound like literally like a few blocks
from where I live so so yes the point
being close your laptop people be here
five dragon high I mean that's the best
well that's one for those criminally
minded who are like I know more public
libraries for my illicit activities but
yeah the point being I mean I think that
yeah I mean they're markets for
everything obviously if you really want
to depress yourself I had to stop
reading it because it got so depressing
but there's a book called Nick mafia and
it's about organized crime around the
world and like the systems that they use
so depressing though like God just it's
kind of like taken on steroids like that
all situation really all the trafficking
what not turn oh ah
alright now what else you got to talk
about I don't know I got some more stuff
is that the Royal you meaning meaning
you are well lit here I'll mention a
couple things
so people have asked me about mics I
haven't talked about this one I use this
all the time that I use for podcasting
so this is the by a company called
yellow tech it's German
and this is the i-x
so this is an all-in-one mic that levels
without using any external software and
so it's it's a really really cool piece
of hardware and ends up sounding like
you're in a studio half the time even if
I'm recording an intro or something I'm
not it's a wireless airport no it's not
Wireless you just have to have to pop
the pop the card out or you know
interest where you can plug it in so
it's all self-contained so I can I could
go like man on the street and do an
entire interview get hours and hours and
hours tens of hours if the cards big
enough and this is what you use your
podcast with you give one of those the
other person I will use this if I'm just
recording intros or sponsor reads or
something like that when I am in person
like what I did with all sorts and Egger
then we had just an an h4n it's a zoom
recorder and then to old-school like
stand up when I use ease though because
these do not I mean I could use these
but these are somewhere between 600 and
$1,000 and the other mic sure fifty
fifty bucks yes did you pay for the
expensive recorder which is like $600
the quarter is not that much is about
300 bucks the only thing I don't think
about this is all the start and stop
buttons are like right on the freaking
my accident yeah you have to be careful
I've never had an issue with it because
I don't hold it like this like a flute
with my fingers on the buttons I mean if
you hold it like that it's fine but yeah
this is one of two or three mics that I
use most often and people say they
prefer doing in person areas ie
interviewers will say oh it's always
better in person
I find that less can go wrong if you
record over Skype with EECOM call
recorder and two cheap USB mics so I
generally prefer that so do you have a
dialing number for Skype they call in I
just use Skype no straight Wi-Fi and
they have Skype too right but you don't
turn on video you just have it overall
you know I don't use video because I'm
not recording the video and it doesn't
keep the baby at all it cuts on me all
the time I've had is it it's pretty
solid of 60 or so interviews that I've
done I've probably done forty via Skype
and I've maybe had
you issues and it's almost always
because the other side has something
like Dropbox or Evernote that's sinking
and they'd forget to pause it
mmm that's almost always issue but this
is a great mic if you have a bit of
budget and you travel a lot I I will
just kind of take this with me when I
travel I'll stick it like and you happen
to want it's there so it's there are
injured so if I I have a separate
container that has different mic
headaches you change it you can change
yeah for for the directional or our
dynamic etc yeah it's very cool
so that's that coolest yeah so let's
talk about this at the risk of sounding
like a hipster I'm gonna throw this out
there I just got for the first time a
record player okay and so let me tell
you why it's not the usual reasons
because I think like this is cool yeah
like record players I have been like a
hipster thing in San Francisco for quite
a while like collecting vinyl like all
that stuff my buddy Josh cook you know
he he was selling his record player with
some speakers and he was like hey do is
this something you want to buy any give
me a demo at his house and one of the
things that I realize about record
players is that it is a great way to
break up your day because it forces you
to get up and flip the record and it
also forces you to listen to an album
like all the way through yeah and so I
was on Spotify and I've been using
Spotify and sonís all that and it's so
easy to iconic song I hate that song I
next song record player it's all much
more difficult I mean you have to get
there take up the needle set it back
down and there's something really Zen
about just like putting on an album
analyst especially an old album and like
listening it to the original way was
pressed like in mono right and there's a
certain warmth that comes out of the
speakers that you just don't get with
like digital audio yeah and so you know
I started getting to some really good
jazz and just some like some old Beatles
records and I just Sinatra Sinatra I
have not your live
my house you saw what did you think I
thought it was really fun I I liked the
experience of listening to albums and I
like the fact that musical artists had
to think about the composition of a side
a and a side B in the same way that an
author has to think about like the
composition and order of chapters within
a section and I still think of my
childhood not in terms of singles but in
terms of like Appetite for Destruction I
know
yeah he starts it welcome to the jungle
SCI day ends at Paradise City and then
so on and so forth right I'm sort of I
kind of know the numbers of all the
tracks and that's the story that it kind
of take right and so there's almost like
a screenplay I mean if if anyone has
seen adaptation or read any of robert
Maki's story seminar he talks about so
the flipping of different emotions as
you go from scene to scene and you have
that type of experience in an album
that's constructed well so I enjoyed
listening to old music on an older form
of player and that made sense to me yeah
and I always think like live Sinatra
from 71 or whatever it was that we
listen to yeah made a lot of sense and I
like the tactile experience and so do i
I'm trying to use my hands more just
meaning getting away from like the the
the 8 to 18 inch visual range
that's another theory I have is that a
lot of I trouble that is developing in
people at earlier ages now is from
having this limited depth of field from
hours and hours and hours of yeah did
they tell you I mean I've seen where
doctors have said you know every once a
half-hour or whatever stare at something
far away and like let your eyes like
readjust and I think that this is for me
records has been this like thing where I
put it by my computer so it's in my
office yeah and then it forces me to get
up and walk around a little bit flip the
record get something to drain drink more
water get my head out of email for a
second like yeah there's something we
said about just that alone forget like
the music and other stuff like just
breaking the monotony of all that stuff
bill time out I also bought Michael
Jackson Thriller unopened from the 80s
I found it for 50 bucks on Amazon never
been opened
that was my favorite album as a kid in
Houston listen to it on record
so like I'm literally gonna like the
white jacket this one
oh no what's the cover look like yeah
he's like off to the side yeah the white
check yeah so I'm gonna open that up in
the first time and like have like a
glass of scotch and put it down and like
relive my childhood right there you know
you should get your final also is some
Queen oh yeah that'd be great
or you could get one of my favorites
when I was growing up and I had those
mini LPS designed for kids disco disco
duck also one yeah I highly sang in the
voice of Donald Duck they're too
expensive those venues disco backs you
know that
Ernie's rubber ducky like that right
that debuted on the Billboard charts
which by the way the voice of Jim Henson
did that voice for Ernie and it debuted
on the Billboard charts at like number
18 out of 20 or something like rubber
ducky I don't know good that's crazy
y'all don't like this good that's good
that's good disconnect you Donald I
think you should get some like THP THC
toothpaste or mouthwash and then listen
to disco disco
why mouthwash a toothpaste oh I just
like the sound of it that seemed like a
faster uptake I mean you could smoke it
too but I just thought THC toothpaste
sounds kind of fun do they even have T's
gonna be very wasteful like just spit
out 90% of it yeah yes sir wait who is a
Nazi
don't be not have you been reading
YouTube comments against you have you
watched the videos on YouTube of Donald
Duck as a Nazi are you kidding me this
is like Nazi propaganda with with Donald
oddly like so looting and everything
wait what
yes he was a Nazi no dunk wasn't a Nazi
who made Donald I cannot see why it was
like somebody
if it was Nazi propaganda or if it was
like war propaganda for the US no it
wasn't using it was funny like easy now
yeah you got to read it you know it was
pro-nazi like he's nudie pictures yeah I
saw I read something about how this was
before apparently they were doing this
before what I read was that that was
before everyone realize how horrible
hailer was so it was like there was a
brief period of time I don't know if I'm
totally screwing this up but from what
this one article I saw there's a brief
period of time we're like the Nazis were
not necessarily a bad group yet like
that it was a party that was doing you
know changing it up and like funny
marches yeah and then the large is and
then then everything went to hell but
anyway that's what they said was made
during that time so I don't know this
was disco disco duck before Donald - I
think you're supporting Donald like yeah
what else okay so uh let's see what else
I think that's it I have one more thing
I want to talk about I'm gonna give Tim
a link when he posts us on his blog for
a walking treadmill desk that I have
that I absolutely love it's a little
hard to adjust up and down but once you
adjust at one time like you're good to
go
it's these treadmill desks they're great
because I can set my laptop down I can
just bang out a bunch of emails I
actually can do work at two miles per
hour and I have my Fitbit on so I'm
getting steps at the same time I don't
set any incline it doesn't do any
clients just flat and then I said two
miles an hour and I'll do it two hours a
day and you'll rack up you know 15,000
steps in no time it's awesome the thing
is I found them anywhere from $700 to
like four thousand dollars this one I
kind of like it was $1500 it had a lot
of great reviews and I was like well you
know I'll roll the die it's like these
nice one look really nice
it was on yeah I got Amazon and I got it
and honestly it's a great debt it's
great treadmill Bluetooth syncs with
your phone if you want to do that did
like it does everything and it's like
fifty nine boxes which is expensive but
it's not crazy like five thousand
dollars expensive like some of the
crazier ones yeah anyway I'll put a link
to it on your on your blog the last
thing is that New Year's resolution
since we really haven't covered them
this year I'll talk about one of mine
one of the things I want to do is really
track all of the drinks that I have this
year so just drinking which I should say
is not intended to necessarily reduce
the number no what you have
step one is track step two is reduce
okay so you step process how you doing
so far I've how many tracked and I'm now
I'm starting to reduce how many drinks
did you have in the last four weeks or a
last month last month last month was a
difficult month it was tough it was
tough because listen I had I went to
Napa for a weekend and I went to this
wine tasting event where they do this
like crazy leg thing this is some do
here the more gone and I also was
traveling I went to Germany in
Switzerland and so I was gone for
another week and a half Geno's come with
serious obligations I mean there was
obligations average obligations of yet I
drink a lot of drinks last month how
many drinks I don't want to talk about
oh this is in the name of science okay
in the name of science let me pull my
spreadsheet I hope by the way getting
Google sheets it's a standalone app now
it's great and you can just like keep
your spreadsheet on you oh you know what
also share my spreadsheet on your post
as well and so you can open it up copy
you can save it as your own I'll set it
as read-only to say save as my own and
then you'll have my spreadsheet it does
all kinds of things like it tries to
guess how many drinks you'll have next
month it I made it all in that day
Rosa's business later here's what it
does though here's what I consider good
days are drinks with less than two
drinks
I consider that a good day drinks have
you had drinks with less than three
drinks less than two drinks no I know
days good days last month yeah days all
right now we're on the same page yes
good days eight eight okay that's good
all right
neutral days I consider two point one
two three drinks okay okay that's
neutral it's like I had two Neff drinks
you know since you know I'm counting
wine yeah one beer is one drink one one
glass of wine is one drink one shot or
mixed drink is wandering
neutral days I had six okay it's 17 bad
days what's bad bad isn't more than
three three
yeah baby so but I mean a lot of these
were like three three three you know how
many tours did you have less I'm not
talking about totals right now of X
drinks yeah so I'm doing in average as
well last month was not a good month so
my average like I'll give an example
first day of this month I had 0.75
drinks second a 1.5 third day 1.5 fourth
day one point four to five in one point
five in five I had one of them glasses
of wine and I actually hit my elbow
knocked over when I had a little bit
left so I have one point four to five
I'm dead serious I'm weird like that
tonight I haven't had anything I won't
have any one day I had three four five
night is young alright alright so track
and then reduce yeah how are you
planning on reduce I want to get the
other numbers indicate fair to say three
digits oh I'm not doing anything spare
to say no more than 100 less than a
thousand no I'm saying that like my goal
is to have like four I want to average
out at about a little under two drinks
per day yeah for the course of a month
that's where I'm right now I'm right
about to it so I want to average I want
to go a little under so I'm trying to
drink like one and a half then obviously
go with a bunch of days like this entire
week I'm not gonna drink before I leave
on this trip did you wire the thousand
dollars to DonorsChoose last time you
lost to spent the what one month of I
don't think I technically lost that bet
alright was it a thousand dollars yeah
we can do it next time when we get done
with this podcast will do put my okay
alright sounds good
so a couple of thoughts it's all I have
these are for those people who haven't
seen these so this is specifically for
Arabic but these are busy flashcards vis
- Edie calm I still enjoy using paper
you don't have to there are many
options for using digital flash cards
but what I like about these typically
and I haven't really dug into the Arabic
all too much yet but oftentimes they
will have Wow
sample sentences on them so in this
particular case it doesn't seem to be
holding true that they have these sample
sentences but in Spanish Japanese I have
these for I don't know probably 12
languages and the sample sentences on
back for a Spanish German Japanese
Chinese Mandarin etc and I am going to
be reviewing these and then I thought
I'd show you another fun thing for those
language little nerds out there which is
IPA flashcards so what is it's not
Indian Pale Ale it's the international
phonetic alphabet so the international
phonetic alphabet if you if you learn
these various sounds or phonemes like
hello friend is written that way that
allows you to converse with people who
are teaching any given language if their
language teachers or linguists they can
explain how something sounds they can
write it in a comment um this is just
for pronunciation and the reason that
I've been thinking about all this is I
am going to Monterey here in California
in the next few weeks then two or three
weeks to visit these guys so this is
American Dream U is a nonprofit
organization that helps veterans
reassimilate into civilian life and it
gives them specifically education and
tools and resources for either becoming
entrepreneurs or finding their dream
jobs and got down in Monterrey
unbeknownst to many people is one of the
most effective and famous language
institutes in the world and they do they
send a lot of the top SEALs and whatnot
to Monterrey specifically to learn
languages like Arabic before being
deployed so they've refined their
systems very very rigorously so I'm
going to be you know any Arabic at all
maybe Kalamata be no not really Abu be
Habibi that means like my dear yeah so a
little bit I have a little bit because I
spent some time in Georgia about
schiappa don't know that it's hot sauce
means hot sauce yeah how about z-tune
you know that's the name of a restaurant
on Martin and Valencia olive oil yeah
and Zetas olives zz2 um yeah just in
preparation for your trip to Dubai Dubai
I know my I live next sort of my buddy
Ramsay and he just like would try and
teach me all day long I've got a little
bit I have a little bit but I'm gonna
sit in on an Arabic class to see how
they teach it go I'm very interested and
they're very many different types of
Arabic I'm most fascinated by Levantine
Arabic although one could argue that
Egyptian makes more sense because that's
what I had but although most of the
movies are made in Egyptian Arabic the
modern Standard Arabic is sort of a book
speak it's like Latin as far as I
understand not really used in any native
country but yeah check these guys out if
you're interested in supporting that's
American Dream you it is very cool
organization and then this one I thought
I would show off which is it was just
fun I was sent this by my friend Kevin
Kelly so this is the silver cord this is
a massive graphic novel and it's it's
about a war between humans angels and
robots with human-like intelligence now
why would you pay attention to any such
thing number one the art is actually
extremely good I mean there's you can
see the paneling lettering the incan
coloring everything is great and Kevin
Kelly is interesting for many many
reasons but he is he's was the founding
editor of Wired magazine and is very
well known he's involved with the long
now foundation he's an incredibly
accurate a futurist technology predictor
I mean very few people can match him if
you look at Kevin Kelley's videos from 5
10 years ago
he's just nailing one instance after
another of things that are only
happening right now and he can hit the
time lines correctly often that I
interviewed him for a three-part series
on
the tempera show the podcast but he
sends out letters to his friends once a
year sort of recapping the year and a
trip that he takes with his whole family
and he sent that along with it which I'm
pretty pretty stoked to check out the
other reason that interests me of course
having experimented in publishing in
different ways myself is that this was
financed by fans so this was was funded
entirely by people who wanted to read it
and then printed I think in Hong Kong
beautiful printing I mean they had a
great job so if you're looking for
something to read if you're hearing
about artificial intelligence the rise
of the machines the threat of artificial
intelligence and so on in the news I
haven't read this yet but I suspect that
there are some very interesting
technological observations and also
philosophical questions in this book if
it's if it's Kevin Kelly's usual
approach to things so the silver cord is
worth checking out and spa cents
suite well I don't have anything else to
you that's all I got let me think you
were gonna talk about quarterly yeah so
I've got my quarterly box coming out
we've mentioned Tim's earlier his box
full of crap actually quarterly dot Co
forward slash Tim I think just search
quarterly and then Tim Barry yeah I
think mine's corley dico slash Kevin or
Kevin Rose but I'm doing 100 our box and
I did one for this last holiday season
we had some really awesome stuff in
there and yeah I'm pretty stoked because
the cool thing and I think you get the
same kind of poll is that you go into
these manufacturers or whatever it may
be and you say like hey listen I've got
a bunch of like really kind of like
influential tech people that are kind of
watching what I do and they listen to my
stuff and I feel like that's what these
people are that are watching the show
here and yeah they typically give you
the stuff at cost or like blow costs to
put in your box yeah and so you actually
put a lot more than the actual value of
the box so oh sure the boxes are a
hundred bucks and I think I added up all
of what I was able to put in the last
box and I'm not
looking like retail price because it's
always [ __ ] I actually went on
Amazon and searched for it and like how
much would this cost if someone were to
buy this and it was like a hundred and
forty dollars worth of death for a
hundred bucks and you can sometimes what
I've had a lot of fun with in working
with quarterly is when you go to a
manufacturer or an artist or an author
and you say hey I want to buy two
thousand of X or whatever your
subscriber count is once it gets to a
certain point you can very often do
customized stuff so wrap for example
I'll be right back so this is this is
one of my favorite graphic novels yeah I
got well this is one of yours oh we did
all right yeah so I'll just I'll just
mention it very very briefly a show I
don't think I showed this last time but
so Simon Simon I think it's Billy it
might be piously anyway I was able to
get a unique print run with original
artwork just for the people who got it
sounds awesome yeah check out Lobo if
you haven't seen this amazing yeah so
anyway if you were denied a box around
the holiday time because I ran out I
only had so many things I could give out
if you were denied one we're opening it
back up just do a search for it we'll
link it up in the show notes in the show
notes and if if it's of interest if you
love the idea or hate the idea or
somewhere in between of either of us or
both of us doing some kind of
subscription thing for like a couple
hundred people or a thousand people
where we I don't know give unique access
or goodies of some type to people let us
know so a hashtag random show on Twitter
at T Farris two hours two S's and Kevin
Rose Kevin Rose and as always love your
feedback so let us know if you think
yeah thanks for watching see you guys
[Music]